I wonder whether
The increased access and use of hormonal
birth control
influencing how objective the metrics
are that women look for in men with
regards to education employment future
prospects and stuff like that is
worsening this hypergamous nature at the
moment and also meaning that
apps like Tinder and hinge which are
very easy to put on what your job title
is what your education level is so on
and so forth I wonder whether this is
creating a hormonal profile in women
which further predisposes them to
choosing these types of objective
metrics yeah I know that's really
interesting I think that that's a I
think that that's a fascinating
possibility I mean in in how could it
not I mean it's like we already see the
way that um that hormonal birth control
I mean we see how it's affecting women's
achievement you know since the pill was
made like legally available to women
um the number of uh legally available to
single women which was in the early
1970s late 1960s what you see is that
the number of women who started doing
things like applying to graduate
programs to law school to medical school
um to business school it went up by like
a thousand percent and it was just
because women now could be sure that if
they started that program they could
finish right the employers as well
presumably would be more certain as well
yeah and so it's it's just like um you
know it just like gave women the ability
to plan I mean it's it's you know used
to be for like people like my
grandmother it was like the idea of
going to graduate school would just be
stupid because she unless she was not
you know know like totally Chase yeah
yeah the entire time that she was doing
it she was probably gonna have to give
it up because she was pregnant at some
point and um and so for you know my
generation and younger generations and
and women who came before me who've also
had access to this like what a
tremendous thing it's done for us in
terms of allowing us to make plans and
Achieve
um but because of that you do have this
like little bit of a mating crisis and I
have another little nugget for you to
like chew on and while you're thinking
about this with the pill and the mating
crisis and this was something that was
actually brought do you know do you know
who uh do you know what Dave asper is
yeah the like Health yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I did his podcast and he's
like a really smart guy and uh and we
were talking about my book we're talking
about the pill
and this was his idea and I think that
he's like totally onto something because
it's really it's really brilliant um
really interesting but you know part of
the mating crisis you know part of it is
that women are achieving so much right
so like that's part of it but the other
part of it is that men are just like
totally floundering I mean just circling
the drain and
um and so you know there is some
research indicating that men's
testosterone you know we are not Red
Deer right like our species are not Red
Deer but men's testosterone levels do
seem to be sensitive to the presence of
like fertile women right so so men
um there's been studies where they have
men
um you know having piped in uh the scent
of of ovulating women or women during
the luteal phase and you see that
testosterone levels seem to be sensitive
um to uh cues of female fertility
and so what Dave had suggested and I
thought was so interesting was we have
so many women on hormonal birth control
so much ovulation being suppressed
meaning that there are so few cues to
estrogen like sort of in the air that
could it be that men's lack of
achievement motivation is in part driven
by the fact that their testosterone is
in the toilet
um because of uh the lack of sort of
ovulating women to inspire those higher
levels of tea and as you know
testosterone levels are at a ridiculous
low one percent per year it's declined
by since 1980. I mean think about that
and yes xenoestrogens and yes obesity I
mean there's a lot of microplastics and
phthalates and more time inside and blah
blah blah yeah all of that but um even
you know no matter what they control for
there's still some like factor x out
there that's contributing to um these
low levels of testosterone so I'm gonna
throw out there as a possibility the
idea that maybe it is a lack of estrogen
cues I think that that makes a lot of
sense I mean Roll It Forward even more
and think about the fact that women who
are on birth control that then urinate
into the toilet which then gets into the
water supply which then increases the
amount of estrogen that's supposed to be
consumed by men no idea if there's any
truth behind that at all but if it's the
case that
taking the pill women who take the pill
are
sociosexually slash pheromonially
influencing men's testosterone in terms
of the fertility cues and also
biologically hormonally internally
influencing men's testosterone like you
know roll on top of that poor sleep and
higher levels of neuroticism people
spending time in the house all that sort
of stuff like yeah that's going to drive
testosterone down now the fascinating
thing is that women who take hormonal
birth control are priming themselves for
the kind of men that have lower
testosterone so it's both the cause it's
like the demand and the supply of the
market for this up until the point in
which they come off it
right yeah and it's like they want the
the the provisioning right like like one
a guy who's going to be a provider but
that's also something that's driven by
testosterone you know we know that men's
testosterone levels are associated with
like mating success and all that on the
one hand but it's also associated with
achievement you know men who are CEOs
and and presidents and um you know in
high status roles
um that's that's testosterone too and so
it's like in some ways like we're also
shooting ourselves in the foot right
it's like why aren't there any good men
around who are like achieving things and
like being successful and and maybe you
know maybe there has something to do
with the what's happening with uh with
women's uh sex hormones really
fascinating idea what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]